when I started playing chess my biggest
problem is I didn't know what to do I do
I mean it just look at the position I
could move this pawn this plant this
pawn I could move the knight and I just
didn't know what to do so I came up with
some really bad ideas and oftentimes I
got checkmated just like right out of
the opening I must have lost four times
at least four times before I understood
that my opponent were all going for the
same checkmate I would be black and you
guys if the scholars made I musta lost
four times before I finally got it
that's checkmate
games over we have to start the new game
so very very often I was a victim
because my opponent would attack my pawn
on f7 and it was inadequately defended
and I would end up losing badly I needed
an opening strategy and more important
than an opening strategy what I really
needed was to have a safe King because I
figured if I could have a safe king
maybe it would take 20 moves for my
opponent to beat me maybe 30 and I
thought the longer I could last the
better I would become because I would
get more and more experience so what I
was trying to do whether I was black or
whether I had white is I wanted a safe
King
so I created
I didn't know that it had a name by the
way all of the openings reasonable
openings have a name I called it the
fortress variation okay in the fortress
variation what I was trying to do was
castle with my king as quickly as
possible and my opening move was Knight
f3 and almost always against most
reasonable replies I would play g3
Bishop g2 and castles so this is what I
call building a fortress and boy once I
learned that opening my opponents had a
real hard time beating me they beat me
but I lasted really a long time with
this position the reason why this
position is such as a good one is
because the king is really secure it's
behind this nice pawn shield the bishop
is extra protection standing in front of
the king also this bishop is a kind it's
an ambush on the diagonal the knight
protects the square and the weakest pawn
in my position the f2 Pont is protected
by the rook so I like the fortress
position and what I tried to do when I
was black was do the very same thing
except with black I discovered that my
attempts to make the fortress variation
immediately weren't so good if I tried
to play my fortress they would just
attack my knight right away and I have
to move I didn't know that this was a
defense called the Alekhine's defense I
didn't have any chess books or any
knowledge of the openings I just knew
that when the pawn came here to e5
attacking my knight my knight would have
to move so I started to play the
fortress variation as black by first
moving my pawn up so that way I protect
the square e 5 when they advance
I would bring my knight out attacking
their pawn
they usually defended it and then no
matter what white did I was really happy
because I get I would get to play Bishop
here and castles next and then I got my
fortress then I would lose that it's
okay I didn't lose in four moves and I
would lose in ten and twenty or thirty
moves one time I got a draw yes draw and
then I got really excited after getting
a draw that I wanted to play more and
more eventually I discovered competitive
chess how many of you play in
tournaments and played in tournaments
that's really good
I started late I started as a 12 year
old oh you guys are so much younger than
me so you guys know a lot more about
chess at your age than I did in other
words I'm an international Grandmaster
as in the world's top ten and won the US
Championship four times I played for ten
Olympic teams I beat Gary Kasparov and
Anatoly Karpov world champions and you
guys are better chess players at your
age than I am was because you know chess
I didn't okay so what I like to do with
this class because openings are so tough
openings are so difficult that I just
want to go over again some openings and
basically what I'm going to do is I'm
going to play against you you're the
class is going to play white I'm going
to play black and I'm going to explain
the moves that I'm making and you guys
because I'll call on you will have to
explain why you chose the move you chose
even if you make a wrong move that's
okay I just want to hear the explanation
arguing you want to start us off with
white d4 okay
D D to D for to control the center
absolutely this is a very good opening
move probably as popular today as efore
D to D and then yes that was a different
move than what you chose the reason I
like to play D to d4 is just because of
what our young said I like attacking
these Center squares
I like opening up my queen and I like
opening up my bishop okay I kind of told
you what I'm going to do so I'm gonna
play Knight f6 young man what would you
do C and why would you play c4 also
controlling the center okay
so I'm gonna get my fortress position
and I'm gonna be very happy young man
what would you do e 2 e 3 so what this
young man said is that when he plays
with the Queen pawn opening he likes to
play the move e 2 e 3 okay we're gonna
have you play e 2 e 3 but I do want to
point out one one basic thing when we
have played the move d4 we opened up the
possibility to develop our bishop the
bishop on c1 which is on the white team
is kind of crying it's kind of saying
hey coach get me into the game get me
into the game and when you play the move
e 2 e 3 this Bishop is saying oh man you
block my view okay I'm gonna play Bishop
g7 young man what would you do excellent
and why would you do that to develop a
piece and also maybe to control some
squares d5 and E for now castles now at
this moment I'll just pause for a second
to tell you what what I'm thinking
when I play chess whether it be a grand
master level or the amateur level or the
expert master level I only need to do
three things in the opening the first
one I'm trying for is to get a safe King
to have my fair share of the center and
to have good squares for my pieces at
the moment I develop my first goal young
man yes that's what I've set up I called
it the fortress but in truth today this
is called the Kings Indian defense
that's exactly what it's called
night night g1 - E - okay so why do you
play 90 - what's the idea
okay so you developed your Knight to e2
again a same little criticism as before
this bishop is sort of like saying hey
I'm blocked now I'm kind of clever I go
hi you guys have kind of made a problem
this Bishop is a little bit blocked
maybe you want to play g3 and Bishop you
too so I'm gonna beat you to the punch
I'm gonna play b7 b six young men what
would you do
d4 d5
okay so now why did you play that move
okay so d 4 d 4 D 5
this is advancing in the center it costs
you a move to advance in the center and
that's okay but now this pawn messed me
up that really messed me up that pawn
move because I wanted to put my bishop
here but now you block my diagonal
that's a rotten thing to do but it did
cost you a turn and so I want to attack
this pawn I'm gonna play e7 e6 young man
what would you do okay so now you've you
protected this pawn on me you've
protected this pawn on d5 what I'm going
to do is I'm going to take this pawn on
d5 arguing look
c4 takes d5 okay now remember what I
said earlier about my castles one of the
things I really liked about the castle
is that I protected my pawn on f7 right
now
you guys aren't attacking my pawn on f7
and I'm thinking that your king is still
in the center I'm going to move my rook
to e8 so I'm on the same file as your
king so my thinking is that maybe this
rook will have some nice tricks against
your king I wouldn't move the rook too
soon I would hesitate to leave this pawn
unprotected young lady what would you do
okay
careful careful g3
is a good idea to bring the bishop to g2
but my rook on e8 and my knight on f6
are putting a lot of pressure on this
pawn on e4 in fact I simply want to take
it so you guys have better defend the
pawn because after g3 I'll take your
pawn okay so we need a better move than
g3 young man okay I like that move f2 f3
but do keep in mind that this pawn on f3
protects the pawn on e4 very very good
very very good one of the drawbacks of
this move f3 is it does expose your King
just a little bit just a little bit to a
potential Queen check on h4 just a
little drawback it's okay
everything is okay let me play c6
remember in the opening a key principle
is to control the center so I see that
this pawn on d5 is a very powerful pawn
that scares me so I want to knock this
pawn Oh - what d 6
okay so d5 d6 your pawn is really
cramping me notice that this Knight has
a real problem
it can't go to c6 can't go to d7 I've
got to make room for my knight so I'll
play c5 with my mo c5 notice that I'm
controlling d4 as well as b4 young man
okay Bishop to g5 that pins my Knights
in my queen I don't like that by the way
that's a pretty good move and I have to
be a little bit careful that the pawn
can't can come here one day and I'll end
up losing a piece I don't like that pin
I like that move Bishop g5 by the way
I'm going to attack your maybe I'm not
I'll attack your Bishop with my pond
h7 h6 come on young man
correct so you got a choice you can go
back or you can trade your choice bishop
to h4 very good so you so you step back
away from H takes g5 okay
so now I gotta bring my guys in to play
I'll play Knight to c6 Knight to c6
someone else young man yes what would
you do
white wants to move this pawn out so
that he can bring his bishop here but is
the pawn g3 a good move because I get to
g5 trap the bishop so let's move the
pawn out two squares so that you can
bring your bishop into play in a moment
it kind of blocks the I'm not sure what
it does but this is okay this is a good
move that's a reasonable move now notice
that I still need to get my guys off the
back rank I could put my bishop here but
it kind of doesn't have as much of
diagonal this is a an open diagonal I'm
gonna play Bishop a6 are you know what
would you do
Bishop to h3 okay so now you guys are
preparing to castle ooh I don't like
castling I was hoping to grab your King
in the center okay now this is going to
be cool I'll take your pawn think about
this one think about this fine young men
what would you do hey Queen that's what
I wanted to hear oh I don't know did I
sleep usually grandmasters don't just
blunder their queen now I'll admit I
made one or two mistakes before I became
a grandmaster but I was I did what was
called a speculative sacrifice I just
lost my queen for a pawn at the moment
but I'm gonna take your night okay so
are you what would you do take back with
the pond very good now at this moment
I'm a queen behind I'm a queen behind
but check out what dirty tricks I have
in mind I can take this pawn with Shaq
your king you can't take my bishop
because it's in a pin so I could take
this pawn with check and then take that
rook I could take this Knight right I
take this Knight the Queen could take my
bishop my rook is is here oh my what is
going on so what should I do
hmm I'll tell you what I'm going to do
I'm going to take this night with my
bishop so now at the moment I've got a
knight for a queen you guys are winning
you're ahead but it's pretty wild who
wants this fun young men
yes but be careful your queen is being
attacked
aryen Queen 2 c1
okay so with Queen to c1 you're you're
protecting this and that would be
checked - right
oh my goodness with a discovered attack
against the king oh my another move I
could make too is I could take this but
oh I have so many difficult decisions
I'm not sir I'll tell you what I'm a
greedy I'll I'll take this pawn and I'll
make a check to your king
are you which one King f2 and now I'm
going to take this rope is very what
what can I do
come and show me tell me what you're
going to do what are you going to do
whoa you're not my bishop out that's
pretty good okay very good so let's say
I knock your Bishop out I so that was a
good trade that was argent
I was a good trade rook e1 okay and
let's say I knock this pawn out so I got
I get upon
oh you mean yeah I like that I like that
young lady what would you do
rook - II - why would you play rookie -
by the way okay yes you don't want to
lose the rope to the bishop
you could have traded that might have
been good - I'm not sure okay so I'm
gonna play by the way what's the
material standings here's a second
before you answer count them up what's
the material standings who's ahead and
who's behind remember I sacrifice maybe
blundered my queen I'm not sure are you
who's ahead I may hit three points wow
really
just a second let me congratulate myself
hold on oh that's all good is it true
okay we both have a bishop so that
neutralizes we both have rooks so that
neutralizes you have three pawns I have
one two three four five six seven oh no
you have four one two three four I have
seven so I may have three pawns I have a
rook more and a knight more but you have
a queen so I have a rope five excellent
that's what I want - yes young men
yeah would you pretty good right okay so
rookie two was a good move to get out of
this capture but I think the class you
preferred this yeah and let's see what
would have happened in this case okay so
now things are really wild it's a crazy
game I'm not sure I like your idea
though if you guys get to play Bishop
takes then my rook and my knight would
be toast okay I'm gonna give you guys a
check okay young man what would you do
you're in check King comes back to f1
that's a pretty good move I like that
move now yes I'm afraid of Bishop to d7
you think Bishop to c3 to play rook here
that's pretty good I was actually going
to move my knight the reason I moved my
knight here is because you guys have me
scared I'm really really frightened that
you're gonna take this part young man
so this is a dilemma you have two good
moves and you'll want to make them both
but you can only choose one so the
choice first of all is to take a pond
that's pretty good the second is your
Queens not doing a lot here maybe you
want to move her down there so I could
take a pole of the class how many want
to move their queen how many want to
take a pond
okay so I think the class won this one
the class really wanted to grab this
pond oh my okay now I have to think of a
good move because that was a that's
tough when you guys grab my palms like
that okay what could I do one thing I
could do is to try to get this pawn
going up the board I'm not so sure about
that
actually another thing I could do is
maybe come over here and grab that pawn
I could go Bishop see now Bishop c3 my
choices are pretty pretty limited it's
tough it's tough I'll tell you what I'm
gonna do I'm gonna bring my knight here
you do okay now you guys like my
position okay are you on what would you
do sorry okay young man
King to g2 okay so what that does is it
kind of escapes my clutches I was well
rookie one so the point was was that I
could check and skewer your queen I
could take your queen but the problem is
that the king is in the way of the Queen
right so now I tracked your queen the
purpose of this class is to emphasize to
yourself we just were having a
conversation
you made moves I made moves but I was
trying to explain to you my way of
thinking what I thought about a
particular move why I thought that move
III in the opening was wrong or why I
found the move Knight II to a little
suspicious so that's what grandmasters
do that's what all strong players do is
they verbalize their thought process if
I go here he takes me there but who's
ahead young man yes
yeah well about I'm I'm about to be a
knight ahead because I'm going to take
your queen or your Queens gonna take my
rook I got so and I have more pawn so
we're gonna stop there but I wanted to
emphasize to you how important it is to
express your thoughts okay one of the
things I did as a kid and I was starting
to play chess is I would get a notebook
and I would write down my thoughts about
a game so if I played in a tournament
game the game was recorded and then I
would write down my thoughts young man
after the game I'm sorry I meant to say
I would go home and then analyze my my
god